good afternoon
I want to thank Perry Hoffman for
inviting me here and of course for her
strenuous worked to help these patients
and their families across ten years we
should celebrate that I also want to say
happy Mother's Day to all of you for
whom that applies
I think the mothers of our country are
helping helping our civilization survive
and without that I'm not sure we would
it's a it's a distinct advantage and
disadvantage to talk after all those
wonderful talks this morning and my
temptation is to throw away my talk and
try to get into a dialogue with each one
of those speakers I would rather do that
but that's not what I've been asked to
do so I'll try not to do that and my
task is equally difficult because at
this point because of the food you have
ingested the blood is going to your
stomach and it's my I've been told by
Emily it's my job to keep you awake so I
will try to do that and unfortunately I
don't have a lot of jokes I was
impressed by other speakers this morning
the amount of humor wonderful humor and
I don't have very many jokes and that's
not a joke okay but I wanted I do want
to relate somewhat to the speakers
before me and then see if I can tie them
into what I had prepared first of all I
found Stacie's talk extremely moving and
enlightening I think she's still out
signing books I just want to pick up on
a few themes that strike me as quite
relevant to all of us who try to be
therapists or coaches or whatever to
borderline individuals
she said my skin
is my barrier and indeed I think
probably the central core of this
disorder is a hypersensitivity to other
people and difficulty understanding self
and others in the relationships with
other so the skin the shield to
protection that's all extremely
important she said be slow to
pathologize differences among people I'm
going to talk about that today in terms
of where the National Institute of
Mental Health is going in terms of
research from now on research now on is
going to focus not so much on borderline
as a category but borderline as
different domains of dysfunction and
these domains of dysfunction are seen as
cutting across all of us so that's one
of the reason I think that Charlie
Swenson applied they said DBT is being
applied to this disorder this disorder
this disorder in part that's because the
domains of dysfunction cut across those
categories in DSM for dsm-5 has a
different orientation we will find out
with time whether it's a better one but
it is different Stacy also talked about
her attempts to connect to a boyfriend
and several men and I think that
connection to others especially in a
heterosexual homosexual in a sexual
romantic relationship is extremely
important in borderline patients it
actually it's important across all of us
and I'm amazed that there isn't more
attention paid to that at least overt
attention and the other one and I think
Stacy hinted at was the
I mean of the treatment that she
received in the course of her young life
so at what point in the domain
dysfunction did she meet certain people
that raises two extremely important
points the whole phasing of the disorder
and how it unfolds and Therapist
differences believe me I'm a fan of DBT
I'm probably oddly enough I've probably
known washer Linehan longer than even
charlie Swenson Marsha and I both grew
up in the streets of Oklahoma and our
parents knew each other and Marsha wrote
an article for me way before she was
known for DBT at that point she was
studying depression and suicidal
behavior in the context of depression
I've known her a long time so I thought
Stacey I can't
many things that I'm going to try to
talk about in a somewhat abstract
academic way I think stacey has said
much better secondly I want to tell you
I had a wonderful experience this week
in New York City at the American
Psychiatric Association you'll meeting I
was on a panel organized by John Oldham
and on the panel were Peter fauna gay
the father if you will of MBT which Lois
is going to talk about this afternoon
Martin bomas the face of DBT across
Germany and the European world John
Gunderson who was one of the first
people to look at way before DSM 3 to
look at criteria to then articulate a
diagnosis for this disorder myself and
then a discuss and Antonia knew
who's a brilliant neuroscientist at
Mount Sinai and I think the panel
suggests a potential direction of where
we're going in the next 10 years there
seemed to be enthusiasm but some
sobering thoughts the sobering thought
is that all that there's a lot of
treatments now that work including of
course DBT that has the most data with
it but when you really get down to it
it's hard to see that one treatment is
really that much better than another in
each treatment there are people who
respond and there are people who don't
and so and in each treatment as I'm
going to try to describe for you some
domains of function change especially
the ones that you've heard about this
morning and some domains do not and so
we we've come a long way in 10 years but
we have an awful long way to go so phone
Iggy talked about the multi-faceted
aspects of mentalization
so all the ins and outs of what it means
for a normal person whatever that is to
process perceiving another person
understanding another person responding
to another person and back to a feedback
loop in the interaction sequence Martin
bomas and not just a thought to you all
martin bomas and some of his brilliant
colleagues have a multi-site sinner
grant in heidelberg and Mannheim
they have several million euros not
dollars euros
to study all the aspects cognitive
neuroscience etc all the aspects of
borderline personality of sort and I
think sadly enough as Nima chose money
goes down I think we're going to be
superseded in the world scene by
research centers like this but at least
that will profit us in our future and
Antonio knew who talked about the
centrality in her mind of this hyper
sensitivity in interaction with other
people and how do we target treatments
to that Center so then to take a page
out of dr. sledges of opening comments
even though it's after your lunch I'm
trying to keep you awake but I'm also
trying to do something else I'm trying
to introduce you to maybe a somewhat
different way of thinking about
borderline personality disorder not
totally different from DBT but maybe
slightly different which then might lead
to some treatment differences and as dr.
Slade said not just openness to others
points of view but how do you connect
them and I'd like you to think about how
you connect what I'm going to say that
has to do with a theory of personality
functioning and then object relations
theory how you could approach that in
relationship to what Lois is going to
talk about next which is attachment
theory I think one of the most powerful
theories we have about human functioning
so with that is introduction also let me
add that I'm sort of agnostic about the
best treatment I'm not sure that's the
best question really I think the best
question is what's the best treatment
for this particular individual at this
particular individuals time in the
progression of what's going on and then
of course you've got these
Mendes therapist differences so there's
a lot of variables in this process so if
time allows I'll talk about the
essentials of what we call transference
focus psychotherapy what's the
theoretical basis of it what is the
current context of treatment development
which I've already implicated talk to
you about and then there's the powerful
implications of the National Institute
of Mental Health what they call the are
Doc's initiative the research domain
initiative so in other words I'm sorry
that's probably a strange word yeah okay
the idea being that a lot of these
disorders as Charlie Swenson talked
about have common neurobiological
psychological behavioral dimensions
across the disorders and so treatment at
least research will be begin to focus on
those domains not so much on the
disorders okay
as I said what is the best treatment for
this particular borderline I think
that's not as I've said not a very good
question I think how can one shape a
tailored treatment to a specific patient
with severe personality sort by the way
I have never found a borderline
personality disorder patient who only
has borderline personality disorder
that's one of the first things you
should think about that all these
individuals have a range of axis one
axis to and so that's the reason the
research domain orientation might be
helpful to us so I'm not going to talk
very much about TFP I think if you want
further information about it you can
contact us and I don't want to spend my
time on that per se just that I would
say this that any implication that
Charlie Swenson gave you that TFP would
be like his analyst is totally
wrong totally wrong his analyst I'm
happy for Charlie I've never had
psychoanalysis and I guess Charlie is
profited from it I think that our
treatment I for one have not and when I
go home tonight no I don't have any
jokes but I will you know what I'm gonna
imagine Charlie running like a goose
Charlie you're incredible okay so so I
just want you to know that there's many
treatments for borderline now and they
share a lot of common elements they all
have clarity about the pathology they
have a clear rationale for treatment
approach for their treatment approach
they structure the treatment process
that seems to be across studies a very
very important phenomena which seems
obvious but it's not so obvious there's
the presence of a consistent you know
dogged therapist who won't give up and
there's a focus in all these treatments
on the here and now
one myth might be that the analysts
would talk only about your past TFP and
all these treatments focuses on the here
and now and all of these treatments in
their own way develop an expectation for
change things can get better you stick
with it things can get better what's
unique about TFP is that the goal is
change beyond symptom change including
and I'll talk a little bit about this
the reappraisal the reassessment of your
internal representations of yourself and
other people we think that's a driving
force in human nature of course reduced
aggression and impulsivity and social
relations and very much important we
think and here's where the field
is lacking a an improvement in work and
intimate relationships I think to
generalize I'll try to give you some
data on it our treatments are very good
at reducing symptoms reducing cutting
the you know suicidal behavior reducing
affect dysregulation but many of these
patients continue not to work and many
of these patients continue to have
serious difficulty in their especially
their intimate and friendship
relationships so I'm trying to indicate
where I think when peri Huffman calls us
all together 10 years from now I hope
I'm still around where I hope the field
can go next I'm gonna skip that I don't
think that this is just some of our
randomized clinical trials there's no
doubt that DBT has more randomized
clinical trials than anybody it's
extremely impressive and I don't want to
be the one that rains on the parade but
I must tell you that I think there's a
growing number of people that are
dissatisfied with the money and the
yield from randomized clinical trials
there's many uncontrolled variables and
it so far has not led us to understand
how the treatments affect the changes
that they really affect we have an awful
lot of work to do this is one of our
attempts to show that while transference
focus psychotherapy does reduce symptoms
it tries to address the question of how
does it reduce question it reduce
symptoms and we think it operates
through mentalization which you're going
to hear more clearly about from Louis
next and we used particularly Dan aai
method to try to show that the ability
of the borderline patient after a year
and TFP improved
their ability to reflect on themselves
and other people in a meaningful way in
their relationships this is just the
data I don't want to dwell on that so
what's the what's the theoretical basis
behind a TFP and not being an analyst
and for many reasons I'm not going to
talk psychoanalytic jargon I'm going to
try to normalize some of the thinking
for you and first I'm going to point out
something that is kind of amazing I
think ever since DSM 3 at 1980 we've had
the benefits of having personality
disorder in the diagnostic system and
that's been very helpful it's allowed us
to use criteria to select samples and to
investigate it's been very helpful but
it's a funny thing the American
Psychiatric Association has gone through
three or four iterations including now
without once mentioning any kind of
theory of normal personality functioning
doesn't that strange when you think
about it so what how does the normal
person again whatever normal means how
does that person function especially in
interpersonal relationships in a smooth
flexible way it seems to me all of our
treatments ought to take a look at that
to then begin to figure out how the
deviations occur in the developmental
pathway and how we might pull those
deviations back to a normal path now the
best personality functioning theory I
know of is that of Michelle and shota
you have these slides in your booklet so
I'm not sure I'm going I have time to go
over them in detail but let me just tell
you about Walter Mischel very
interesting man at Columbia University
psychology professor
and for many years he did not believe
that people have a personality actually
when I first met Marsha Linehan Marsha
sort of said to me John I'm not sure
people have a personality I'm concerned
about suicidal behavior which as we see
has certainly paid off Walter Mischel
also said I'm not sure people have a
personality because if you look at them
in different situations they behave
differently so in some situations people
are honest so if they go into a
supermarket they don't steal laxatives
like some patients I know and then when
they go to pay their taxes they're not
so honest about it so is there really an
honesty trait across different
situations so Michele said I'm not sure
there is such a thing as personality and
then to fast forward some 2530 years
later Michele does feel or does think
that there's personality at this point
but it has some wrinkles in it and one
of the wrinkles and I think it's very
relevant to borderline personality
disorder is that any clinician knows
that under certain conditions people
with that diagnosis behave just like
everybody else
at least from an outward behavioural
point of view under other situations
they do not so one of the tasks of our
assessment is to find out in which
situations they have difficulties and
which ones they do not so what so
Michele talks about human functioning in
terms of the signature of the person in
terms of if-then situations if this
occurs this person will behave this way
so he is found out
that if you track people across time and
situations across situations they behave
differently but in the situation they
behave very consistently over time so it
means that we have to get beyond just
talking about emotional dysregulation
our borderline patients are not
emotionally disregulated at every point
in their path
they have emotional dysregulation
usually in certain specific contexts and
of course that's where skill training
can be quite powerful if of course the
skill training relates to the specific
skills in those specific situations
so I'll just sew this graphic short of
sort of gives you a story about that and
what what he's saying is that the
environmental situation stimulates what
he is called cognitive affective units
so when you walk into this auditorium
and you see somebody that you know or
don't know it stimulates a cognitive
combined with an affective response in
your head and he says that these
cognitive affective units are organized
that they guide your behavioral
expressions these are then observed by
other people and they feed back to a
loop that comes back again and of course
Stasi articulated those kind of feedback
loops with her parents with her
boyfriends much much much better than I
could ever do so TFP then and if you
think about this this is very much like
what's called an object relations theory
in a psychoanalytic orientation and it
suggests to
me that any what any adequate treatment
of personality of sorta including
borderline personality disorder must
assess this this this and this and the
feedback loop and it was sort of implied
I think by Charlie Swenson
it's where in that feedback loop can you
begin to effectively intervene notice
this is a psychological theory so it
assumes all kinds of biological bio
social predispositions genetic
biochemical somatic and so forth
now of course that assumption is going
to be carried forward into the
foreground in the our Doc's initiative
of NIH so I would suggest that any
substantive model you're going to hear
about object relations theory and caps
theory here Louis will talk to you about
attachment theory any Theory worth its
salt would talk about the foundations of
the model the structural features of the
model some taxonomy to help guide your
assessment and intervention strategies
so I think what's its virtue and its
difficulties is that object relations
theory grew out of psychoanalytic work
it's based on many many sessions with
very disturbed personality sort of
people that's both its benefit I think
it's got to be furthered by laboratory
tests of these functions and of course
it assumes then the validity if you will
of the patient reports so object
relations theory in short the term
object refers to a person with whom the
subject has a relationship object
relations is the quality of the subject
relationships with others an internal
object is a representation of another
within the mine
of the subject so here's the heart of
the thing and this sounds an awful lot
like cognitive affective units that
Michelle and show to talk about so it
presupposes an internal representation
of yourself an internal representation
of other people and related effects and
so this I'm just going to leave it at
this this therapy then focuses on that
particular phenomena that particular
phenomena as he gets played out in the
current relationships with the patient
and other significant people especially
intimate others like boyfriends husbands
and so forth and in the relationship
that evolves with the therapist and of
course the goal is to help the
individual grow in their understanding
of what's going on in themselves and
with other people in this regard it is
very very similar I believe to MBT I'm
gonna this didn't come out very well but
I just want to make the point that Kerr
burg I think in some ways predates the
are Doc's which you're going to see more
about coming out of ni mhm predates that
in the sense that he's often talked
about categories so there are categories
here like hypomanic personality and our
statistic personality borderline
personality but these are seen in a
multi-dimensional space so in other
words it does not assume that all people
with the borderline diagnosis are the
same and in his way of thinking about it
and we do have data on
these people vary in terms of some key
variables one variable is going from X
introversion to extraversion
so some of us are very externally
oriented toward people toward our
environment and some of us are very
removed almost temperamental II to avoid
to stay apart and you see that in the
personality disorders with paranoid over
here and narcissistic and history onic
over here you also see levels as you go
down
so in this theory as you go down you
have more serious lack of identity lack
of a sense a clear sense of self and
other people you have more primitive
ways of defending self and you have poor
relationships with other people and as
you go down aggression
tends to increase and in fact as you
come down beyond borderline to
anti-social and what's called in a bad
way malignant narcissism the whole issue
of moral values begins to be corrupted
so there's a big difference between a
borderline person who's also antisocial
who does not have a clear value system
who goes against all structure and
values and one who does not okay so what
it means and just very briefly in this
theory is that it's focused this
treatment is focused on real-time
functioning and observation so there's
the relationship between the patient and
the therapist and this can be either hot
or cool it could be conflicted or not
conflicted
and the therapist has a dual role of
being both a participant and observer
enough to help articulate with the
patient different points of view of
what's going on my suspicion if we got
into a discussion would be that Charlie
and others could point out exactly how
this process is also down in DB T but in
somewhat different ways now it's called
transference focused psychotherapy
because there is an assumption of
transference so there's is an assumption
that's easy shall we call them cognitive
affective units with a perception of
self and other and related effect
there's an assumption that these will be
played out in the room with the
therapist and will be played out in the
real world with relationships that make
a lot of difference to the borderline
individual I wouldn't assume given the
caps theory I wouldn't assume that the
transference in the room is exactly the
same as relationships outside they may
or may not be but I will assume that
those are going on in the current scene
and they are a large part of what's
disturbing the patient's world and then
of course the idea being that these self
self s self and object other are
transferred onto the therapist so the
therapist can both stay calm
hopefully and be observant I'm going to
skip some of these ok so then what what
do I think we know after 1012 wend and
Martius start 19 what charlie 1980 91
yeah okay what do we know since then I
think we know a lot that we didn't know
that
first of all there are many treatments
for borderline personality disorder and
the number of treatments grows every day
I think the latest one that I'm very
impressed with is general psychiatric
management John Gundersen is developing
that and suggests that good general
psychiatric management following certain
kinds of principles is probably just as
good as any of the specialized
treatments but keep in mind as I told
you not every patient responds to the
treatment so it may be that some
patients who don't respond to general
psychiatric management may need one of
these more specialized treatments also
what do we know we know that treatment
effects on social functioning are
generally poor and while we know that
all these treatments work at a symptom
level it's not totally clear why and how
they work there's multiple meta analyses
out there and they show exactly what I'm
saying
that it's hard to find in a consistent
way any one treatment that's really that
much better than the others so consider
for example Shelley macmaine's 29 2012
study where she compared DBT to general
psychiatric management so at the end of
one year of treatment the treatment
effects were the same after two years
the effects on symptoms were pretty much
the same but here's what I want to bring
your attention to and this was a
carefully carried out and designed study
but here's the important thing that
follow-up 51 percent were not working
nor in school change from sixty percent
before one year of treatment
for treatment 40% were on disability and
at the end of treatment
39% on disability so what does that mean
don't be negative about that I think
that we have come a long ways in ten
years we're very good at structuring
treatment at reducing symptoms reducing
suicidal behavior I don't think we're as
good I don't think we've given enough
attention to what I'll call love and
work now marry Santorini has followed
these patients for 16 years
Louis has probably been part of that
team and it's it's powerful work because
you know we don't want to know just what
goes on across sexually we want to know
what goes on across time and here's my
take-home point that symptom remission
is more common in borderline than social
and functional recovery as I've said and
only 40% of the patients compared to 75%
of access to disordered patients other
than borderline attained social and
functional recovery lasting eight years
and here's the punchline
vocational impairment is the main reason
that borderline patients failed to
attain or maintain symptomatic and
social vocational functioning back to
Stacy did you notice that where is Stacy
she's still signing books she's smart
I told her after I gave me permission to
talk about her talk but I wanted to
check with her later to see if I had
distorted it now I guess I'm going to
tell her I didn't
maybe hurry did you did you notice
Stacey's determination to get education
to get out of town to get a profession
to get some some skills there's some
learning some some vocational place in
the world
I found that extremely impressive so
here's our docks and here's where I
think our research at least the United
States probably not in Germany is going
to be heavily focused on they're going
to ask us to talk about border lines in
terms of domains of dysfunction and
they're going to require us to measure
these debates across biological
psychological and behavioral realms I do
not agree with the assumption of this I
don't know I don't think Stacy would
either but the RDoc classification rests
on three assumptions one mental
disorders are disorders of brain circus
that my friends is reductionism if
you're a taxpayer you are paying for the
application of reductionism and put it
any rate disorders a brain circuit that
can be identified with tools of
neuroscience and data will yield bio
signatures for clinical management we
will see I'm not sure so here are the
domains that NIH talks about negative
valence systems positive valence systems
cognitive systems and systems for social
processes and of course when you apply
that to borderline patients you can
think of predominance of negative effect
relative absence of positive effect and
variable effortful control variable
ability to modulate and
trol attention on the way to effect
regulation and of course insecure
attachments to others
distorted representations of self and
others so then if you apply that to our
existing treatments and I I don't
pretend to do justice to all these
treatments we don't have time but if you
think of the columns going down TFP
tries to approach negative valence by
exploring distortions and
representations of self and others
cognitive systems by reevaluation of
representations and social processes
changes in the representations of self
and others and of course then behavioral
change
DBT focuses on mentalizing and DBT
functions focuses on functional analysis
skill development mindfulness and skill
development
now here's my pitch I'm sure not all of
you would agree with me but it occurs to
me that we can all three stay in our
silos we can stay within our columns and
just keep doing what we're doing right
or we might be more creative about it
think about integration and think about
what we can do if we came across this
way what if we came across this way and
used the best combination of strategies
and techniques for the individual
patient depending upon the strongest
domains of dysfunction in this
particular patient I think it's worth
thinking about
I have fine okay alright so the
implications of where we're going I
think of our docks is probably patient
heterogeneity what are the domains of
change and the search for biomarkers by
the way we have research I only have
five minutes we ever start showing that
there are different kinds of borderline
patients we also know so this biomarker
thing our latest study we took we only
had a short amount of money Germany has
much more I'm very jealous we took ten
patients we gave them a year of TFP and
we did an fMRI before and after to see
if we can pick up changes at the
cognitive psychological level ie reduce
symptoms reduce impulsivity etc and to
see if the systems at the brain level
are beginning to change like you would
expect and the very simple answer is I
hope soon you can read this in the
literature is that yes we compare post
treatment to pre treatment we find
effective lability improvement that is
as it goes down it correlates with
decreased amygdala activity and increase
singular activity so in other words as
as the treatment helps the patient grab
on to methods skills methods for
reducing effectivity and understanding
self and others you also are getting
burnt changes in the brain somebody said
I think Emily said that when she went to
school she was told that borderline
patients do not change
I can one-up her I went to school much
earlier than Emily did and I was told
that the brain you have is the brain you
have and you have no chance Clark and
that's the brain you have it's not true
the brain can change too so I've got to
get to the take-home message we have
tremendous advances all existing
treatments are limited and I'm sure all
of us are going to keep going
and I think some of the main questions
are how to capture borderline
heterogeneity what are the domains of
dysfunction and maybe we can begin to
investigate the various levels of the
organism neurobiological cognitive etc
this isn't my own thoughts take
empirically supported with a grain of
salt this is the only the beginning as a
clinician focus on the individual
patient
each borderline is quite unique I would
say develop your own local way of
matching borderline patients to
treatment like the one mentioned by John
Gunderson and I do think some form of
integrating treatments across those rows
as opposed to just down the columns is
probably going to occur in the near
future thank you for your attention
alright let me just take a look at we
have here so I think maybe you can speak
a little bit to if people were
interested in getting trained in
transference focus psychotherapy or
learning more what are some of the
resources out there for people yeah I'm
not involved in all the training you
really should contact Frank Gilman's who
is our director of training I can give
you email addresses and so forth if
you'd like what's happened our crew is
using the Internet to do live
supervision across the United States and
Europe and so there's different ways to
get supervision when you're at your
place and the supervisors somewhere else
and we do this in multiple language good
what kind of connections in the model
that you presented do you see between
BPD PTSD and like toxic stress how do
you think the environment is playing a
role and the personality yes I think the
environment is playing a huge role
that's the reason I said that our Docs I
think is frankly reductionistic so it's
leaving out the environment and I try to
emphasize the environment in the Cape's
theory so clear there's no doubt I think
that early trauma and and beyond just
the trauma is somewhat obvious and
terrible but I think also how do
ordinary households I was talking to
Louis about raising her children so how
do you take a five-year-old in a
one-year-old that's somewhat impulsive
because the brain systems aren't fully
developed for maturation for modulation
how do you teach that well most parents
put that into words
they put feelings into words they put
thoughts into words they
how I feel how you feel how I might feel
differently how you feel and I think
that kind of less obvious lack in the
environment is operating very very
intensely in borderline backgrounds is
tfp an impatient program yeah no it was
originally when Charlie Swenson was at
the Westchester division Frank Gilman's
ran one unit and Charlie ran another
totally different models but at this
point you know inpatient length of stay
is like six days and 43 minutes and I
mean that literally you know the
insurance company calls the patient was
admitted today and they call tomorrow
and say as the patients still suicidal
you know so no it's an outpatient
treatment and by and large I think all
the forms of treatment now think that
probably hospitalization is not a good
thing as Charlie implied in his story
and that you want to get the patient
back into outpatient treatment so that
the real-life experience of love and
work can keep operating
we don't want therapy to become the
patient's life we want the therapy to
help the patient get back into the
normal environment
and one more if if it's it seems that
from your talk that you were saying that
the effectiveness between DBT and MPT
and TFP and general psychiatric
management might all be similar why do
you think it is that DBT has been so
popular as Charlie was talking about
earlier we were talking in lunch I had
lunch with the gentleman who grew up
like I did in Oklahoma where Marsha grew
up and I think that we I don't know if
you know the phrase Dust Bowl in Pyrrhus
ISM so if you're going to survive in
Oklahoma you've got to know how to
change a tire you've got to know how to
do this to that
survive and I think Marsha brings that
kind of down-to-earth practical
orientation and I think that that's that
appeals to a lot of people I also think
that the setting you work in makes a big
difference if you're in Germany where
the government I I don't know what you
all know this will pay for therapy two
and three times a week for at least a
year or if you live in Manhattan where
nobody it's hard to get into a general
clinic at all like our waiting list I
was talking to Stacy the waiting list at
paint Whitney's very long I think what
you do and what you go for makes a big
difference and I think DBT has a great
appeal for for applying it across these
horrible settings okay well we have time
for one more I'm gonna ask so we
actually had a couple questions about
are there applications for for
individuals who are seeking a couples
treatment and also somewhat related but
also like applications of the treatment
for individuals that have different
ethnic backgrounds first of all couples
I would just say there's no quotes
manualized TFP for couples but if you're
training residents like i do i've told
residents for many years if you want to
see transference and you don't want to
wait for a develop over time see a
couple
because when you see a couple and you
ask them about their relationship boy do
you see transference in action and I do
a lot of couples treatment I find it
very interesting I find it in some ways
much more intriguing and difficult than
individual treatment because well let me
put it this way if you want to know
about transference and you have a couple
see the wife and ask her to describe
herself and then ask her to describe her
mate and then meet her mate and compare
what she said to what you experienced
and that's that's some level of
transference and then so you begin to
think about how would you work with that
with a couple in the room and the other
one ethnic differences well that's
that's really interesting I just have a
random thought so I think the answer is
we have done TFP in north america south
america across europe we have not done
it in asia and i remember when they were
developing the the interview for
personality disorders the question was
in the japanese culture which has a
totally different orientation to effect
an effect regulation would there be
patients who would meet the criteria for
borderline personality disorder because
the the thought was maybe maybe they
will not but actually the prevalence the
incidence and prevalence there was
exactly the same as Western culture so I
kind of think there are many domains of
dysfunction that cut across ethnic
groups they may get expressed in
somewhat different ways well thank you
very much dr. Clark